hello everyone and welcome to Game one
of the 2018 Watchers championship
between Magnus Carlsen and Fabiano
Caruana at the venue of the championship
is Oberlin College for those of you who
might want to come and can't locate it
like myself it's actually Southampton
row 12 that's the address it's really
hard to find it I found it in an article
that was written when they decided on
the venue of the butchers championship
match now it's a really a crazy game one
you would not expect from around one
World Chess Championship match but I'm
sure you're all going to enjoy it now
prior to this game Kosovan Caruana have
played several games of course in
classical time format out of out of all
the games they have played in classical
time format Crossan has won 10 games
Fabiana won won five games and 18 games
were drawn so it's very interesting how
this game will turn out and also a very
interesting aspect is that Carson could
choose whether he wants white pieces or
the black pieces in the first game and
he chose the black pieces and the
witness he kind of announced that he
immediately wants to fight so we're
definitely gonna see what happened like
I said sorry about not posting the video
yesterday I had to go from Heathrow to
Auburn College and it's it's an one hour
drive so when everything was over I
couldn't even wait there for the effort
to game to finish as it lasted over six
hours so when I got back
Heathrow also a one-hour drive it was
already past the 11:00 p.m. and the the
trip really took a toll on me I decided
it was better to show you the game
yesterday after I've had my rest and
prepared everything properly including
the photos which are compliments of
Nikki Riga including these two profile
photos a very nice photo of Caruana
from the press conference and a very
nice photo of course and from the actual
game yesterday I know if you've already
seen the game I'm sure that's fine there
are plenty of great and by far better
videos than this one you are watching
but for those of you who have for some
reason decided to wait for my showing I
would like to congratulate you for being
an excellent subscriber now let's check
out some of the photos before we check
out the actual game so here we have a
very nice photo of Caruana it's from a
firm yet
today preparing to make his first move
and very interestingly here you have
Woody Harrelson alongside Feder
president Arkady dvorkovich
oh it's a it's not a rare occasion that
Woody will show up for a chess game
especially for such a big chess event
and he was invited here to make the
first move for the player having the
white pieces and also the next photo you
will see is one of the greatest photos I
believe ever taken in chess
championships here you have a photo of
woody playing the wrong move because he
has the Fabiana which movie do you want
to play and Fabiana said efore but would
he heard d4 and he actually well first
he knocked over caranas king and only
only after that he played the d4 the
wrong move and then Caruana had to ask
the arbiter whether he can take the move
back and play of course efore and of
course the arbiter allowed it I mean
you're not just gonna play a move
because it would he played it but woody
really really had a good laugh regarding
in this whole situation and there we
have Carlsen he was also very troubled
by that d4 idea but then when he saw
efore then everything was alright
then you have woody was of course
invited to the official stream that was
run by a unit poker in honor Rudolph
also Daniel King joined them at on
occasions and would you also give his
opinions on the position that was
currently on the board now between
Carson Caruana
also here is a very nice photo of me and
Daniel King during his break I managed
to catch up with him have a few words
and the Nicky was just in the vicinity
so she took this very nice photo I'm
very happy about that and here is a
photo of Richard Carr myself and Woody
Harrelson before the game actually
started and it's also a very nice story
I would like to share as when I got
there I didn't even notice that the
Richard and woody were there as they
were like all the way back in the corner
playing their game woody was defending a
very difficult position of the Bangko
gambit and it was actually Richard who
approached me he said Antonio it feels
like I know you for very long
time I've been watching your videos for
a whole year then he introduced me to
woody and we had a couple of words I
asked him about carnage is it happening
or what not he was a very affirmative
and well it was a it was a very
enjoyable experience to say the least
and he would he really had a lot of
questions he stayed not not up up until
the absolute end but he let's say stays
on six hours for this game and he also
had some very interesting questions like
what is time control what is this what
is that and Richard actually explained
it extremely thoroughly so you know
really really nice to see when someone
you know what his background is is so
interested in chess and hand shows up to
an event like this but that being said a
lot of useful links will be in the
description below be sure to follow any
career and all of her social media a
links to that will be in the description
below as well now let's check out this
very nice game Caruana has the white
pieces and he opens with not 2d for the
move woody played but rather efore and
okay we have a c5 by Carlson he already
wants a fight as he did choose the black
pieces for Game one and he goes for the
Sicilian we have Knight to Knight to f3
Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 dinesh
meet Dean of rosalie more attack and
it's very interesting they will follow
up the up to move seven they will follow
a game they played in the 2015 Tata
Steel chess tournament which cousin won
with the black pieces - brilliant extent
but here it's actually costing who the
first from the variation played in 2015
we have g6 the same as was played then
but captures D captures this is the
standard theory of this opening d3
Bishop to g7 thin cat wing the dark
square Bishop h3 a nice move taking away
the g4 square for cost from Carson's
Bishop Knight to f6 and here we have a
nice to see 3 and here in 2015
Crossen preceded would it be 6 and then
the game continued Bishop to e3 e5 where
of course the 5 pawn cannot be captured
if you capture the night
personally for opens up an attack
against the knight on e5 and so on and
so on but here it was actually carlson
who instead of b6 now went Knight to d7
now the c5 point is protected like in
the b6 variation but now also it comes
with a much greater control of d5 square
and also the bishop is now free to roam
the board we have Bishop to e3 Caruana
was not obviously prepared for this move
maybe he was but he did take some four
minutes this is the first thinking time
of the game this is Bishop three to
remove Carlsen continues with E 5 we
have castles and now Carson again goes
b6 but it did take him some six minutes
for this move as the other moves cousin
played relatively quickly so I don't
think this is a new position for him I
think he actually came very much
prepared and it was just like a boat
panic moment where he takes six minutes
to think about a move he already
prepared but okay Knight to h2 here
Caruana took 18 minutes for this idea
because he really has to figure out how
to approach this because you have to
consider a lot of things so how will I
play this will he castle will f5 come at
some point and what not so he decides to
go for this plan Knight to h2 and f4 to
challenge this C 5 pawn and to open up
the F file for his rook well he will
develop the Queen at some point and he
will definitely double rooks on the F
file so nice to H 218 moves for this
move 18 minutes for this move sorry we
had nice - f8 getting the night to f8 so
the bishop can also come into the game
we have f4 by car on as planned this was
a it's 2 Caruana some 12 minutes for
this move so basically for this night to
h2 move followed by a 42 car 1 a half an
hour and ok well he captures on f4 we
have route captures on f4 and now Bishop
to e6 developing the bishop which is a
very nice square for the bishop as you
know that white will most likely double
the rooks and the F file and the bishop
on e6 will serve as a huge protection
that is f7 pawn and since Caruana does
not have a light square bishop cousins
the bishop pair will definitely be a
powerful
Dean also instead of this specialty sex
move you don't really gain anything by
by attacking this rope here with the
bishop to h6 or bishop here you white
will simply move the rook and even
exchanging dark square bishop does not
really work for black for example
captures captures and now your pawns are
on light squares you have a light square
bishop and you have some dark square
weaknesses so not really gaining
anything here after night to have faith
we have f4 like planned he captures an
f4 rook captures an f4 and Bishop to e6
we already mentioned that and now Luke
goes back to f2 you don't want to leave
it on my fort so Carlsen can attack it
with the bishop so you know better to be
safe we have h6 taking away the g5
square from corona species but also in
some variations preparing g5
so now as h6 is a potential target a
Caruana
uses it to develop his queen with an
attack against this point okay for now
it's defended twice but you know still
have to keep a keep an eye on it
and g5 by Carlsen when and when everyone
in the whole saw g5 it was a really nice
moment everyone said oh yeah
something is definitely happening here
and it definitely is because white
already castled king sized Carlson's
king is still in the middle but there is
no real way for Corona to take advantage
of this you're not gonna do anything
alongside the semi open F file as
constant controls it very nicely and
there's really no way for you to execute
a central breakthrough here so rook a to
f1 doubling up on the F file and here we
have Queen to d6 calls and now develops
the Queen and prepares the Castle
queenside so now the other rook can come
into the game as well and here a corona
took some again 16 minutes for his next
move he goes Knight to g4 and yeah it I
mean it does require a lot of thinking
as well what happens if h5 is played for
example attacking this Knight sure if
you go back and then comes g4 Black is
breaking through most likely black will
win this game as if you if you open up
his King side it will be very hard to
hold this but the problem is after a
move like that after Knight to g4 if you
go like this
then you have this in-between be five
attacking the Queen and also now you
will be able to capture on g5 nice to f6
is an idea so if the if the Queen moves
then you get Knight to f6 check captured
captures and here white will definitely
be better as you will be able to capture
here even if g4s played you can block it
with h4 so nothing dangerous is
happening here okay after Knight to g4
we have queenside castle by Qasim and
now comes Knight to f6 an excellent
square for the knight of course Carson
is reluctant to capture the night you
don't want the rook to infiltrate on f6
a very nice dark square you're not gonna
be able to kick it away so Knight to d7
challenging Coronas strong knight on f6
and now Knight to h5 Corona goes for
Carson's Bishop but Bishop to e5 and now
again we have this very nice
relationship between a bishop and the
knight the bishop is controlling all of
the squares the knight can use to to
retreat so there are no possible
retreats here and oh it's a very hard
for whites to actually find the move
here okay you could go for some a4 ideas
we play a waiting move
prevent some future b5 and whatnot but
Khurana decides to go for the immediate
the g4 now this night here is protected
and also well you don't want to play a
slow move and allow Carson to break
through with f5 so now Caruana is
definitely controlling the f5 Square
immensely this is definitely now our
Caruana square but it comes with the
different problems here across and
immediately played f6 as the night on h5
still has nowhere to go
the bishop and Queen are very nicely
controlling the g3 square the f4 square
is very nicely controlled by the phone
so Carson's plan is Bishop here and
capturing the night he wants the double
these pawns and then the Queen will
perhaps be able to at some point play
something like Queenie six Queen
captures on h3 and so on
but okay b3 not allowing this a two
point to become a target so the knight
now can move but also not allowing some
sneaky ideas like c4
Bishop to f7 attacking the knight and
here we had Knight the d1 by Caruana
here the engine's evaluation gives this
as a huge huge advantage for black and
here definitely Carson was considering
it most likely as he took some ten
minutes for his next move
he goes for a very nice pawn sacrifice
with nice to f8 but a seemingly deadlier
idea was Queen to e6 now the threat is
the very simple mushroom captures here
on h5 and after pawn recaptured then of
course the Queen will already be eyeing
the h3 pawn so this was not played but
it would be very uncomfortable for for
white here white would have to play
something like Knight g7 and then after
the Queen e7 it would be a very awkward
square for the knight but okay after
this night the d1 would have a knight to
a fade by Carlsen offering the f6 pawn
and Caruana captures it with Knight
captures on f6 and now of course not
capturing with the bishop and allowing
this rook to infiltrate but rather night
to e6 now cousin wants to take advantage
of this beautiful f4 square for his
knight Knight back to h5 and this is
where Caruana really gives cousin the
momentum he needed instead of this knife
to h5 move Khurana misses the did well
not deadly but at the equalizing move
Knight to d7 now this comes with a
double attack against the bishop on f7
and also it comes as an attack against
the bishop on e5 so here if you capture
it and then simply rook can capture on
f7 and always well here for white your
rooks are nicely doubled on the F file
and if not after Knight to d7
you could go Bishop to f4 not allow this
Knight to capture the bishop but then
Knight can simply go back to f6 as the
bishop is no longer controlling the f6
square and if you repeat something like
Bishop to g3 attack the rook rook f3
Bishop goes back now you can repeat
Knight to d7 and we go around so a very
nice move this Knight to d7 for Caruana
but instead he decides to go 492 h5 and
okay Carlsen grabs it
the bishop captures the pawn captures
and now comes Knight to f4 and excellent
square for the knight of the night is
just a monster here are already
attacking the h3 pawn threatening check
to capture the rook so you definitely
want to remove
which Caruana does the shop captures
pawn captures interestingly Bishop
captures seems also like a very nice
move but the problem is after white
moves the Queen as its attacked you can
no longer ever move your bishop because
you would unleash the two rooks onto the
black position you can never push g4 or
push any of the points on the King side
because your Bishop becomes vulnerable
and of course there's really no way to
break through here it's actually white
hood have the advantage here so
capturing with the Jeep on makes much
more sense f3 will be an idea in the
future it does open up the G file for
Karlsson's rooks and you know anything
goes now we have looked the g2 blocking
the the G file but Crossin goes look h2
g8 and nonetheless and now comes Queen
to e2 also interesting idea is a rook to
g4 saying that okay if you want to trade
rooks at least I will undo my pawns but
it comes with a price
for example rook captures H captures yes
you have fixed the structure of your
pawns but after look to g8 attacking the
g4 pawn queen g2 defending now comes
Queen to d7 with a double attack against
the g4 pawn with the threat of capturing
whites Queen Knight F - the only move
that defense the g4 for now you have
your knight and Queen stuck here
guarding the g4 pawn and you don't
really have all that much to do here you
will just have to wait for the rest of
the game to see how black will punish
you and torture you perhaps an engine
would go for this but a human would not
so Queen to e2 and now comes rook
captures on g2 we have Queen captures on
D - Angie - Quinta e6 by Carlsen and
here again we have Knight 2 F 2 which is
the only move that will eventually allow
you to block the G file if you try to
escape with the King I didn't have to
look the g8 attacking the Queen Queen
moves rook g3 it will be a white will
not will no longer be able to hold this
so you do have to close up close up the
G file nice to have to Carlsen goes rook
the g8 attacks the Queen and now nice -
G for blocking of the G file which is a
very nice light square as Carson has a
dark square bishop there's no
real way to kick the night away from
there but there are other other
available options for Carlson here he
goes
Queen to e8 attacking the h5 pawn and
there is no good way to defend it so in
reality his pawn sacrifice was not
really a sacrifice we have Queen to f3
and now comes Queen captures on h5 there
was no way to defend at the pawn now you
cannot capture on e5 of course as the
the knight is pinned from the rook
so King to have to Caruana on pins we
have Bishop to c7 not allowing Corona to
capture the bishop and here we have King
to e2 this is a move that again really
allows Carson to create something
beautiful
a move that Corona probably should have
played his he 5 and a lot of people
mentioned this there was a lot of a lot
of people were following the super the
Norwegian supercomputer as analysis
under mobile phones and they said oh
yeah II five such are such a monstrosity
of a move really blocking the bishop and
you know threatening ideas like Knight
to f6 the black would not really have
any good moves here after something like
King b79 if six is coming and okay you
don't have to trade Queens you have
Queen to h4 but after King II to look g3
attacking the Queen you will be able to
capture here and after Queen captures
rook captures Bishop captures on e5 you
will have rook here and now Bushell
characters on f6 rook captures and after
rook captures on h3 you would have this
position where Carlsen would be up a
passed pawn a pass to H pawn what would
a very inactive King it would be it's
very unlikely that you would be able to
push here for anything so instead of
listening to e to e5 an extremely strong
move
I think Kasparov was a was invited for
the st. Louis Chess Club live coverage
and as part of all also mentioned this
idea so everyone was really impressed
how the old champion have found found a
way out so so nicely but okay King to e2
and now Carlsen really has an
opportunity he plays Queen to g5 this is
a strongest move and in fact by all
standards are winning move because now
White has nothing to play e5 is now
useless if you play e5 now
you've just moved the Queen from the
h-file h4 h5 attacks at the defender of
the e5 square you would either have to
move the knight here or suffer terrible
losses after you move the knife Queen
Catherine's on a ePHI with check this is
over but after Queen to g5 okay and
Knights the h2
I have played by Caruana and it's
interesting this is move 33 so you need
seven more moves to reach down control
this is I think it was a at about this
time woody asked what's this time time
control thing and then Richard explained
it very nicely to him but yeah here
Corona had like six minutes for the for
the next seven moves or six moves this
is more 34 and it's really intense such
a such a crazy position with so little
time on the clock it's just I mean it's
just not fair to chess but okay here
Carson goes h5 and this is one of the
moments where he also could have gone
for Queen to e5 and everyone was waiting
for him to go for Queen to e5 now the
idea is rook the g3 is coming if rope
the g3 comes it all hell will break
loose
so Queen f2 first getting out of the out
of the rooks way after rook drops to g3
so now Queen the b2 and now with the
rook raining down on you from one side
and the Queen threatening to capture the
entire Queen side this will be this will
be done for white after King d1
defending now comes the b5 this is the
move cross and most likely missed
because it comes with with terrible
threats of either c4 or Bishop to a5
controlling this entire dark square
diagonal and then Queen b1 check would
be would be huge because you will be
able to capture on c2 again with check
and here it would be really hard for for
whites to deal with it after a if you
play something like Queen captures on c5
I it doesn't work king b7 simply getting
the King to defend the c6 pawn and now
after you try to block the G file h4 h5
will be enough for black I have to
remove the night here comes check King
has to move and now of course you'll see
it this is the the power of of potential
in the F pawn f3 check the King is
defending the rook on f1 King has to
move
Queen captures it's all over one of the
one of the ideas but okay cousin goes h5
still doesn't change much it takes away
the g4 square from car one last night so
you will never be able to close the G
file and here Khurana plays rook to f2
and here we have Queen to g1 also a
possibility was Queen g7 Queen g7 now
with the idea that after black threatens
the attack the Queen side white will try
to defend it with Queen h1 to flip over
to the Queen side Queen B - and now
Queen d1 defending the c2 pawn
but now black can even capture an A -
but also you can infiltrate immediately
with the rook rook the g3 now you're
attacking the a two point you're
attacking the h3 pawn and after rook to
f3
unfortunately this doesn't work but you
know feel free to pause the video here
and figure out why this wouldn't work
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations rook to f3 does not work
for the following reasons those of you
who found it you were in excellent
analyst of ideas that never happened on
the board and for those who just wanna
enjoy the show it's actually rook to g2
check checking the king and attacking
the knight rook blocks and now comes
rogue captures on h2 it's very nice move
rope capture so now after we check will
pick up the rook as it opens up a
discovered attack from leadership to the
rook King will capture captures black is
up a piece winning the game but okay
instead of this idea Queen G seventh
here her cousin goes Queen to g1 and
still this is very much playable nice to
f1 Caruana doesn't allow Carlsen to
infiltrate the Queen side this way so
this is one of the reasons perhaps Queen
to g7 was better as the corona would not
be able to prevent infiltration and here
cousin plays the absolute strongest move
that was suggested by the supercomputer
says say it is h4 so now rook the g3
comes up with with a very deadly threat
here karana most likely should've played
'if I've at least get some breathing
space for his Queen open up an attack
against the c6 pawn but here
want to actually play King 2d2 he wanted
to bring his King over to the Queen site
to be able to protect the Queen said
with his King but also to get away from
all the action on the King side and here
it just it just doesn't work
Carlson first place King to b7 and here
we have C 3 but now Bishop to e5 by
Carlsen here again cousin didn't go for
this B 5 B 5 seems to be a crucial move
in all of these continuations because
now whatever white plays and white
really doesn't have any moves here
something like came to see - we have
ripped to g3 white has to wait for black
to go rule g3 now you will have to
capture Knight captures and now after
pawn captures attacking the rook rook
moves and now comes Queen 2 a1 so Queen
will still be able to attack the Queen
side d4 White has to make room for his
King Queen captures will check King d3
Queen captures and b3 White's position
is falling apart King has to run Queen
c4 check Queen blocks and now after
Queen to e6
what is up in the exchange but this
exchange really isn't doing anything
Carlson has to protect at past points
another passed pawn here it would be it
would be impossible to hold this for
white but ok
after c3 cousin doesn't go for v5 he
goes for Bishop to e5 he wants to pile
up on the CT pawn now we have came to c2
and now comes Queen back to g7 this is
move 39 Caruana has a few seconds to
decide what to do here his c3 pawn is
attacked twice and he has to make a move
he has a few more seconds to reach time
control after that he will be awarded
more time of course but it's a very
important decision and here corona
simply decided to go for night - H - he
wanted to repeat in invite person to go
back windy one and try the same
variation again and this was in fact the
correct idea for Carlsen here Carlson
allowed himself to go deep into time
trouble he also had a few seconds here I
think he was down to like 10 seconds or
even below 10 seconds when he made his
move he decided to capture on c3 when in
fact he should have just repeat
Queen to g1 and then went for the same
idea after Caruana blocks this then go
b5 and then go into the same variation
that we've just mentioned but it's a I
mean it's a terrible choice to be to
have to make with with a couple of
seconds on the clock to reach time
control across and captured on c3 and
now Caruana has this freeing move Queen
captures on f4 now Queen to f7 check is
coming
Bishop to d4 you don't want to allow the
trade of Queens and the bishop to stay
one herbal on c3 so corona simply played
Queen to f7 he forced a trade of Queens
and now after kingly six captures
captures we have rookie to rook f3 is
not possible to defend eh free porn
because ruiji to check would pick up the
night so instead we have rookie - and
now rook g3 going after the h3 pawn we
have 94 and now rook captures on h3 so
Carson still has a past h1 but it will
be it will be it will be held to prove
that this can be pushed to a win and he
will definitely put Caruana through
he'll be 5 karana does have a passed
pawn himself and of course passed pawns
must be pushed so he pushes it
we have rook f3 Carson has to hurry back
with his rook to be able to stop the
past pawn ECX rook f8e 7 rook to e8 and
now comes Knight h6 it's not possible to
force the rook away from the H Square as
the knight would need a couple of more
moves and the pawn on e7 is on a dark
square across and has a dark square
bishop so he will definitely be able to
attack at which he will h3 Carson also
pushes his past pawn we had Knight to f5
and now Bishop to f6 not allowing 96 now
if the white knight and moves cousin
will simply capture the pawn we have a 3
and now b5 finally cross on display b5
but it is far too late for such
activities we have before pawn captures
pawn captures and here Bishop captures
on e7 a very nice move by Carlsen now of
course if you play rook captures then
look at verse 9 chapters you will no
longer be able to prevent cousin sage
bone from Queenie
so after Bishop capture
only seven night captures we have h2
Luke has the capture it rook captures
rook captures and now rook to h6
defending the c6 pawn king blocks and
now Carlson is still up upon but as you
will see the game will go on for some
three more hours but there is no way to
do anything here
unfortunately for for the world champion
who really missed a lot of chances here
but okay king c3 rugby 7 rogue g6 King
to c7 rook to h6 rope to d6 offering a
trade of rooks of course white cannot
indulge in this rook trading rock to
reach 8 and now rook the g6 rope to 8
attacking the pawn on a 7 king defense
rope goes back we have looked to g5 rope
to h7 check King g6 and now Luke to h6
check rook to g1 trying to go behind the
king rook to c2 a king to see to not
allowing it Rock f1 rook to g6 rope to
h1 and rope to f6 this is already more
67 so second time control has already
been reached
Luke to h8 and King to c3 here Carson
knows that there is very very little
chance that he can actually put this for
a win but if I be his loved one in time
he does have some 8 minutes on the clock
so he might you know if he gets him to
like one minute to where he really has
to make some choices then perhaps there
is of course a possibility of a blunder
rook to e8
now F for a d4 we have roped the eight
and now Rock to h6 rook to d7
we have wrote wrote the g6 of white that
doesn't really have anything to do here
he will simply have to wait what Carson
can come up with pink to c7 and now Rob
the g5 will look to f6 rook the d6 rock
to g8 Luke to h6 and rook to e8
back attack in the a7 pawn king rope to
h3 came to see - Luke - 83 and now keep
the b2 attacking the rook and now rook
to a for King to c3 defending the pawns
and now a six if you decided to play
something like King b7 attack the rook
and for example after the rook moves to
play a 5 okay you will be able to
capture here with white rook captures
and then you
even have d5 and now if you captured
then white will be able to recapture one
of the ponds and it will be a draw and
if you pull the pond then white draws
easily by simply keeping on checking the
black ink and if the black ink
approaches the C file then a nice check
will win you the C pawn and again it
will be a draw so no way to actually do
any progress with any eventual a5
breakthroughs he said was played with a
rope to a trait rook to a3 chirping bee
to Rose III King see to rub the g5 with
rope to h6 a rope to d5 attacking the
pawn king defense rope to d6 of course
avoiding the rook trade roof to g6 came
to see - now came back to be seven kings
III roof g3 check in situ rook G one
rope to h5 rubgy to check in see three
root G - Richard King see - Luke - g4
King to see three King b6 rook h6 rach
gia I'm not allowing White's to push d5
of course that would be very unfortunate
for black rook to f6 now comes Luke to
h5 now rub the g6 rogue back to h3
checking c2 Luke h5 King to c3 Luke d5
not Rho goes back to h6 king c7 rook age
seven check King roblox
of course you cannot trade Luke d6 rook
to h8 rubgy six rope to f8 rope the g3
check King to see - rook to a3
we have rook checks King goes to d6 and
now comes Rock to a7 finally constants
King is able to enter enter the position
but it will not it will not mean all
that much King to d5 we have came to be
- and now comes rock to d3
if Roque Ford and thinks that King to c3
will defend the pawns adjust as well so
instead we have worked to d3
now comes Luke captors and a 6-row
capture son d4 and now King to b3 rook
to e4 pink the c3 rope the c4 check King
the blocks of course you have to defend
the b4 pawn king before I will look to
b6 King de rope to a6
rook to c2 now
back to b6 rope the seat reach a king B
to rope the c4 king b3 King Defour rook
to h6 king D 5 and after Luke 2:8 it was
in this position and move a hundred and
fifteen that they decided to draw this
game and it's very interesting this is
now the second longest game in a World
Chess Championship match the first one
is still I think game game 7 in the 2014
match between Magnus cross and
Vishwanathan Anand but you know if he
already pushed it this long you know he
perhaps he could have pushed it a few
more moves just to make it the longest
game ever in a watches championship
match you know just putting it out there
but yeah such a such an amazing game
especially for Game one of any World
Chess Championship match really Carlsen
came prepared
he already you know deferred from
unknown line they played in the Y cons
that Tata Steel chess tournament in 2015
then he created a lot of chances but he
faced something that he said in plenty
of interviews before the match that he
creates chances but he is unable to
capitalize on them he is no he says
about himself that he's no longer able
like some two years ago to really push
water out of any stone so perhaps it
happened again in this game but I mean
Caruana is simply a monster defender the
positions he defended like like the one
you know where her cousin said quite
said the haters also that was a really
impressive position to defend but yeah
we do have one nice photo here it's a
photo of Carlsen after the game from the
press conference he has to attend one
after every game you don't have to see
the press conference you can just look
at this photo and you will know how call
Carlsen felt after this game because if
he managed to win Game one with the
black pieces it would be a huge blow to
Caruana not only point-wise but it would
be a huge psychological blow you know
losing with the white pieces in game 1
not not an easy thing to recover from
but who knows he's a young fellow at the
top of his game maybe maybe it wouldn't
really have that
that kind of an effect on him but yeah
that's basically the game I do hope you
enjoyed it there will be a lot of useful
links in the description below so feel
free to check up on all of them a lot of
cool people to follow will also be in
there also I have to mention do follow
nikki riga and on all of her social
media to have some excellent photos from
this and every other huge chess
tournament i would like to thank you
Brant Ian Scott Ian Sykes a given man I
Samuel the Russell and Larry Bowman for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous videos here
thank y'all for watching and I will see
you soon with Game two of the 2018
Watchers championship match hopefully I
will be able to do this one much sooner
than I'm showing you Game one but for
those of you who really have waited for
my showing of Game one once again
congratulations you are an excellent
subscriber thank you and I will see you
soon